[Music]
yeah tomorrow at 10:30 the funniest show
it's it's amazing okay deal with it
describe the premise of the show Howie
what has this work okay we put cameras
in restaurants and and bars and public
places then we kind of we could see the
people and hear the people that come in
we're kind of like Snowden in that way
the SA and I say so and then we pick he
wasn't making a prank shift he gave me a
great idea so then so then we we see
them say there's a mother and daughter
sitting there right the host Theo von
will call we'll say let's get the mother
back there we send away over and make up
some excuse to get the mother back we
say you want to be on a game show you
can win thousands of dollars if she says
okay we give her an earpiece send her
back out and we have celebrities tell
her to do things for money for
challenges like if a woman sitting with
her daughter we may say you know what
tell your daughter for five hundred
dollars tell your daughter you're
pregnant and it's not her father's for
five hundred dollars deal with it
oh that's just the beginning you should
see some of the things that are those
are people so unlike other shows this is
all done spur of the moment you're using
real civilians real real real people
they're having him you're putting them
in your piece in and you're saying do
this do it they do it heidi klum did one
where she wanted to walk out she was the
celebrity giving people like she goes I
don't want to just sit back here I want
to be part of it a guy sitting with his
girlfriend in the bar she says I'm gonna
come out there I'm gonna I want you to
say your girlfriend oh my gosh there's
Heidi Klum I've always wanted to slap
her ass and go and slap my ass as hard
as you can with a girlfriend the
girlfriend's gonna say no don't do that
we'll give you $1,000 if you do that let
me just tell you the guy slapped Heidi
Klum's ass harder than I've ever seen
and that's not where the slapping ended
there was yelling there was slapping I
don't want to give too much away but
10:30 tomorrow night right here on CBS I
am so proud of this show 9:30 central
you part of the family join in and watch
also I'll tweet live at Howie Mandel and
I want everybody to be a marketing
expert I want you all everybody who's
watching everybody here tweet watch TBS
1030 because there's money in it for all
of you not for me or anybody at the
network
let's tell everybody to watch it
all right well listen we know what's
going to be very funny it's deal with it
premieres tomorrow and I don't think
we've said the time and Channel enough
7:30 right here on TV
[Applause]